think about this today's topic so this
one comes straight from tim poole's
channel for a lot of people who are
super chatting they're asking about
vaguely about something that you guys
are accused of doing that i don't know
anything about and they're they're super
chatting as if i would know what it is
but i can i can't i can't ask you just
this simple one adam griffin says can
you ask why these clowns tried to take
down abba and preach with fake dmca
strikes
you want to go into it
awkward
hey man hold up what's this guy's name
adam griffin says can you ask why these
clowns yo adam griffin shout out to you
because apparently this [ __ ]
paid money to tell tim to ask the
question hey man listen some of our fans
i appreciate y'all y'all legitimately
paid money to call these dudes
so adam griffin i don't know who you are
but if i'm ever in your city on tour for
doing stand-up let us know we'll buy you
who will be here
hey man it's the holiday season and it's
just in time fresh and fitter the gift
that keeps on giving all right so they
went on tim paul's podcast
and you know had a bunch of talks
because you know i'm ru who is uh fit in
this case uh he's a fed federal agent i
was
who knows okay but anyways he's out
there talking about the case and sharing
his in insight since he was a fed agent
and um
somebody asked a question to tim and tim
didn't know anything about this but he
still read the question so what does tim
have to say about this as well as fresh
let's find out can you ask why these
clowns tried to take down abba and
preach with fake dmca strikes what
you want to go into it yeah
it's it's a yeah
yeah
yeah it's funny because it's the same i
i i that he did when you went on there
live and you asked the question straight
up so i just want to ask you about that
why do you think i might be blue built
um well from what i remember i'm trying
to remember i would say uh
like
hmm i'm trying to i'm trying to think
like what which video was
oh yeah so what's up yeah i heard you
were talking about the podcast
what did i say and then fresh was like
well actually what you said and fresh
through them under the bus
fresh is so unaware and lacking in any
awareness think about this so so
basically uh we have a lot of people
that talk about us on the internet and
some of it is slander some of his
defamation and using our content in
their videos and we're like okay cool
we've waited out for a while for you to
stop you're still doing it so oh you
know what cool
now we're gonna take legal action
against you because obviously we're
attacking our character and our
integrity so at that point hey it's all
for a game yeah i mean yeah okay so i
want you guys to beat what he said he
said yeah we did copyright strikes
against you saying you misused our
contact why because you attacked our
character
criticism
and their response is let me file a dmca
strike which has nothing to do with
criticism
just remember this let's keep hearing
simply put if someone breaks into your
store right and use it takes a broom off
you have a hardware store it takes a
broom off the shelf and starts beating
you with your own broom and won't leave
and does it for four months what are you
gonna do
what the [ __ ] is he talking about
let me let me what happened is that you
have a store that you sell brooms and we
told you that that broom is garbage
that's what we did
we left the google review
that's what we did we left the google
review saying
your broom asked me for a fight now that
broom don't want to fight and that broom
doesn't pick up death that's what we did
that's what we did
that's the only thing that we did we
didn't break into nothing we didn't
steal nothing we told you your broom is
not doing what it's supposed to do you
guys know what it's claiming to do and
that broom challenged me into a fight
when i showed up and i wanted to show up
that broom turned into a dustpan that's
what happened okay so we left the google
review
and that's not illegal
i'm dying bro well you can't file a dmca
over it yeah apparently not yeah so what
they just get it reversed or what yeah
it's it's it's a long story but
it's not okay i'm sorry it's not a long
story youtube was like yo what the [ __ ]
is this yo take this [ __ ] down and your
little [ __ ] ass ran to youtube like uh
we're retracting it please don't delete
her channel please don't delete her
channel and you retracted all your
strikes don't be acting but it's a long
story no stupid you did the wrong thing
right susan wojowski just came in there
with the long slung and slapped you
that's what happened and it's okay but
don't make it sound like it's a long
story and also
shout out to temple who said
uh that's not how it works he just
yeah you didn't hear what he said no
swami and won't leave and does it for
four months
what are you gonna do
well you can't file a dmca over it
apparently not
yeah tim's like uh well you can't do
what you guys did
[Laughter]
tim doesn't doesn't know what happened
tim doesn't know what happened but he
just went off what they told him
he's like that's not how it works
if you want a virus from someone that
didn't know what happened
then there you go
that's not your response if somebody
breaks into it you call the police you
can't just go and shoot up their place
that's not how it works yeah so what
they just get it reversed or what yeah
it's it's it's a long story but
basically simply put the challenges
when it comes to public failures and
defamation cases it's really hard to win
it is yeah which is why you didn't take
this [ __ ] to court because your stupid
ass would have lost a lawsuit and had to
pay us money for the court fees that's
why you didn't do defamation and that's
why you did dmca strikes right that's
why you did that because you didn't want
to actually pay your lawyer all that
money that you made
okay to go to court you could have
that's like somebody hitting you with a
broom okay
that's like somebody hitting you through
it's gonna
[Music]
that's like somebody hitting you with a
broom and then they want to file a
copyright infringement it was like what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] go to the police is the
salt wrong court stupid
there's a time we do to go to family
court because
so if like if i downloaded your video
and then i started just playing clips
while commenting on it it's fair use
hopefully you guys are taking notes
fresh and fraud well
well
go on
oh my god
but this is this is where people are so
that one of the questions about
copyright infringement and fair use is
are you infringing on someone's market
and so that's what i was going to say
because fair use depends on different
countries it's different where depending
where you are but a big thing on fair
use where you know it hurts your ability
to get protected by fair uses are you
hurting that other person's ability to
profit from their own product but this
is this is specific it basically means
like if uh
if you're a photojournalist and you sell
photos for a living
and then you post one you post a sample
on twitter and you say to license this
photo buy it here and then people start
posting it everywhere now you've got
copyright infringement because
even though it's online even though it's
newsworthy and even though people are
commenting on it they're infringing on
your market because you directly sell
this content which means you said
license it from me if you guys do a
publicly available show and people post
and comment on it you got no case you
can't you can't dmca it
you smell that it smells like [ __ ]
[Music]
that was pretty good you know what i'm
gonna say
i smell cookies is that you
that song kills me
i smell [ __ ] is that you fresh
yeah i mean it it depends on where you
are i will just say this just so we
could put a bow on it is we successfully
removed a bunch of videos on on that
yeah that we're not protected by fair
use that right that was another question
the question was about
us you want to see he still wants to
come out as a winner yeah even though he
was completely in the wrong right that
that's that that's that's not that's how
potato this guy is that's what potato is
he's trying he 100 did the wrong thing
did a dmca strike for the wrong reasons
and then try to come out like we did
successfully take down a few videos yeah
yeah you did you gave a couple of people
strikes and i hope tim poole looks into
that all right the fact that this dude's
abusing the copyright system to silence
people or criticizing them because if
you really think about it what we do is
what tim does tim pulls up news articles
from all kinds of different publications
trash is the person who writes it or
says good things about it but basically
tim to his audience will read out
certain articles and be like this is
what's happening but that's what he just
explained yeah
what that is is what we do right whether
you're reacting to a video a news
article a press briefing whatever it
might be okay when these are publicly
available things and you are reacting to
them right and sharing your input
well what omru the fed all right mr fit
what he did to these youtube channels
could easily happen to tim poole yeah
right because the arguments are usually
while you know if people say bad things
you don't think tim criticizes people's
journalistic abilities definitely
people's writing definitely i'm mad at
that i'm saying it's fair use my whole
point being is that the very thing that
fit is trying to take down with these
fake dmca strikes is the kind of content
that tim pool makes and that is and that
they make two because they be reacting
to videos on the channel all the time
you know it is what it is you know we
don't have any animosity towards these
guys it's just like hey man we don't
attack anyone else we don't make hit
pieces on anywhere else anything that
was put up was taken down out of respect
to those other content creators and for
people to continue making content on us
negatively for for months on end it's
it's just like at some point so you
gotta defend yourself right so then
defend yourself
then say
what you gotta say about what's being
said
not the people but what is said don't go
around the bad being that we gonna try
to negotiate and we're gonna try the
legal thing in the views of the system
that's not defending yourself you're
trying to shut people down and censor
people that's what you're trying to do
that's it yeah and at the end of the day
the critiques are still there
everybody's saying well they did a
five-hour livestream it didn't address
any of this stuff that i gave a [ __ ]
about this man still asking women to
throw the [ __ ] at them if you if they
want to come on the pod no no they
didn't debunk that all right and if you
want to believe that believe whatever
you want all right and now beyond that
if they want to file fake dmca strikes
they can go ahead and do as many as they
want okay keep playing stupid games i'm
not mad go ahead you're gonna win super
prices yes but undoubtedly the way that
these guys use their platform you know
and here's another story that came out
too a bunch of people who were
critiquing them had their instagram shut
down yeah because they went on one lady
went on his podcast he kicked her off
after she had an outburst had him the
next day her instagram got taken down
spencer cornelius ig also got taken down
now of course nobody can directly link
that to sheriff's outfit but do i
believe that guys who would
underhandedly use the copyright system
to try to take down channels would also
do the same thing to people's ig's yeah
i probably believe it i don't think
that's much of a stretch because they
themselves will say they'll do whatever
it takes to defend themselves
wouldn't be surprised but hey i digress
all i know is
where these guys are involved there's
always a hot mess and i enjoy watching
it from afar so y'all keep doing you we
appreciate y'all we're going to enjoy
all the adsense money you guys keep
doing here
anything else you want to say
shout out to tim tim who didn't know the
whole situation was like nah
that's where
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
we just try to twist it yeah he's really
trying to twist it yeah shout out to the
fresh shout out the freshers uh so they
were talking [ __ ] and so we found some
dnca strikes think about this think
about this
uh that being said
there are ways you can get a sugar baby
without pain